[موسيقى]
الموضوع بسيط بالنسبه لي ببقى اللي هو انا
زي ما انت قلت اللغه موسيقى عالميه انت
عايزه توصلي لكل الناس يعني اي فنان يبقى
عايز يوصل
احساسه ورؤيته لاي واحد في العالم
وفكره ان انت كنت واجبي العصر ودائما
تشوفي الاصوات الجديده
التكنولوجي الجديده مش معناه ان الواحد
يشوف الترانز او ايه اللي فرقع ويعملوا بس
الفكره ان انت لازم تجربي وتواجبي وتفضلي
حقيقيه لنفسك وللصوت اللي انت عايزه
توصليه
[موسيقى]
انا ممكن اكون بحب طبعا الالبومات الخاصه
الموسيقيه او
الحفلات طبعا لان الحفلات
تتفاعلي مع الجمهور وتشوفي رد الفعل في
ساعتها مش مش اللي هو عملت مقطوعه او او
قلبه ونزل وبعين تبدئي تقري او تقابلي حد
يقول لك اه لا بص الاغنيه دي كانت حلوه لا
انت رد الفعل وبيبقى واضح في الحفله لو
الناس سقفت لو الناس مبتسمه وانت بتلعبي
التعاون ما بيني وما بين الموسيقيين حتى
على المسرح ان احنا نكون طالعين بشكل
متكامل ده دي حاجه بتسعدني جدا
مش انت ليه عاوز تبات في القصر ما هو مش
هينفع بيها قصر بيتقال عليه مسكون طبعا
موضوع الافلام زي ما قلت لك هي بتبقى حلوه
ان انت تتعاوني بقى مع صناع
عمل من جميع المجالات يعني بتتعاملي مع
المؤلف والمخرج في الحاله دي الاستاذ وائل
عبد الله هو مخرج الفيلم ده فيلم بطوله
دنيا الشربيني احمد داوود شريف منير وناس
كثير جدا فنانين كثيره في الفيلم وفكره ان
هو اول فيلم عربي ثري دي دي برضو تجربه
محمساني ومحمساني قوي ان هي كمان بعد هقول
لك العلاقه ما بينها وما بين الدولبي
اتموس لان هو الدولبي اتموس بكل بساطه ان
انت زي ما في ثلاثيه في الابعاد كصوره انت
بتجسمي الصوت مش زي الاول كان الدولبي
اتموس والتكنولوجي دي بتخش السينما تبقي
سامعه الفيلم والصوت مجسم فالسماعات اللي
في القاعه انت دلوقتي بقى فيه
مساحه ان انت ممكن في الهاتف نفسها لو
معاك معينه واغلبي الجودات كلهم كده
بيديكي احساس اللي هو السبيش الاوديو اللي
هو كانك جوه المقطوعه سامعه الاصوات 360
درجه
على فكره في مثل بيتقال غلط
اللي بيخاف من العفريت يطلع الصح بتاعه
اللي بيخاف من العفريت يتهيا له يتهيا له